how do you as a leader motivate your
team to be just as hungry and passionate
as you are and make them want to bust
ass just as hard i don't i think it's
crazy for ceos and owners of things to
expect their staff to bust their ass and
be as hungry as them because when you
own something it's different i want to
buy the new york jets i need like seven
billion [ __ ] dollars
i work 18 hours a day like i don't
expect that from others because most
people aren't insane to like have this
romantic point of view of like not being
able to buy a jets jersey for 20 bucks
when he first came to america to owning
the team i've got a [ __ ] you on me got
it i don't expect that for anybody else
what i want to know is what makes every
one of them tick do you know many people
just want to make 200 000 a year and
have great work-life balance that's
[ __ ] unbelievable and if that's what
you want i want to empower you to do
that i think the biggest mistake that
leaders make is they expect others to
care about their [ __ ] as much as they do
that's [ __ ] ludicrous